okay that's it I am not covering any
more Trump news no more Trump legal
issues I'm done nope even though this
lawsuit has the potential to destroy the
entire Trump organization I'm not gonna
do it
but I know someone who can
get me Spencer the scowl owl Devin I
just want to say thank you for letting
me talk about a subject not a single
soul is tired of hearing about and that
is Donald Trump's legal problems
now of course asking a criminal
prosecutor to talk about civil law is a
bit like asking a baseball player to
opine about golf after all we both use
sticks to hit balls a certain distance
depending on the circumstances so
without further Ado let's get to It New
York attorney general Leticia James has
filed a civil enforcement action against
Donald Trump Don Jr Eric Trump Ivanka
Trump the Trump organization and other
Trump organization officers
better luck next time Tiffany
it's been a busy summer for America's
favorite ex-president his ex-wife died
and was buried on his golf course
Georgia prosecutors and paneled a grand
jury to consider charges against him for
election tampering the Department of
Justice executed a search warrant to get
back documents Trump was storing in his
Florida basement Trump organization CFO
Alan weisselberg pleaded guilty to 15
counts of tax fraud and the Trump
organization will go on trial next month
in fact there are so many legal problems
swirling around the former president
that legal eagle has had to open a
special Trump unit just to monitor them
all today we'll explore the legal basis
for the New York state civil enforcement
action against Trump and while the New
York attorney general case is a civil
matter the case rests on Trump and the
rest violating criminal laws what's more
the members of the Trump organization
have invoked their Fifth Amendment right
against self-incrimination in a related
criminal prosecution all that brings
this case into my Arena but more on that
later first we need to start with quite
a bit of background the complaint
alleges that for a decade Donald Trump
and the Trump organization knowingly and
intentionally created more than 200
false and misleading valuations of
assets on his annual statements of
financial condition in order to defraud
financial institutions during the
investigation mazors Trump's longtime
accounting firm cut ties with the Trump
organization in February of 2020 mazars
announced that his financial statements
it prepared between 2010 and 2021 could
no longer be relied upon the withdrawn
statements formed the backbone of the
state's lawsuit
the complaint alleges that Donald Trump
and other defendants engaged in conduct
meant to mislead mazors in connection
with its work compiling the statements
because mazors was not conducting any
review or audit procedures but rather
was issuing a compilation in which Mr
Trump's and the trustees assertions were
being compiled into financial statement
format many of the fraudulent statements
and strategies remained concealed from
or undetected by mazars the attorney
general contends that the Trump
organization committed fraud for at
least a decade involving conduct across
more than 23 different properties and
other assets when valuing Trump
properties the company would change
methodology on how to Value properties
from year to year or even within the
same year some of the fraud was
allegedly accomplished through
sophisticated accounting sleight of hand
but other acts were apparently blatant
and easy to detect for example Trump
estimated that his own Triplex apartment
in Trump Tower was 30 000 square feet
when it was actually about 11 000 square
feet I always call it massive
sometimes they say huge in 2015 Trump
valued that apartment at 327 million
dollars in total or about twenty nine
thousand seven hundred and thirty eight
dollars per square foot now that price
is absurd since at that point only one
apartment in New York City had ever sold
for 100 million dollars or more and that
sale was a newly built Ultra tall tower
no apartment in the 30 year old Trump
Tower was ever sold for more than 16.5
million dollars between 2011 and 2015
the value of the triplex incorporated
into the statements of financial
condition increased more than 400
percent from 80 million dollars to 327
million dollars the bulk of this
fraudulently inflated value came from
the misrepresentation that the apartment
was 30 000 square feet a property
appraiser visited the penthouse in 2010
as part of the underwriting process for
an insurance policy he noted that his
visit to the triplex was a bit unusual
this was a unique appraisal appointment
before the site visit I was told there
would be only 15 minutes to see the
apartment Mr Trump was home at the time
of the appraisal and wanted to do the
walk through himself I was unable to see
the master bedroom and Mrs Trump's
dressing room per request of Mr Trump
Mrs Trump was sleeping although I was
able to spend slightly longer than the
15 minutes in the house the appointment
was conducted at a speed directed by Mr
Trump and there was not ample time to
take measurements while on site only
after Forbes published an article in May
2017 entitled Donald Trump has been
lying about the size of his penthouse
did the Trump organization stop
inflating the square footage for the
apartment the complaint is over 300
pages and contains numerous examples of
trump allegedly using various deceptive
schemes and valuing his golf clubs to
inflate their values I'm not talking
about the values of the actual clubs but
of the clubs where golf takes place the
statements do not list separate values
for each of the club's facilities
instead the values for those properties
are lump together into a single figure
this was done intentionally to conceal
significant swings in the value
attributed to individual clubs and to
conceal the methods used to arrive at
those values for example the Office of
the Attorney General claims that
Mar-A-Lago was valued as high as 739
million dollars based on the false
premise that it was unrestricted
property and could be developed and sold
for residential use even though Trump
himself signed Deeds donating his
residential development rights sharply
restricting changes to the property and
limiting the permissible use of the
property to a social club in reality the
club generated annual revenues of less
than 25 million dollars and should have
been valued at closer to 75 million
dollars and this is what brings us to
the New York attorney general's civil
enforcement action the New York Office
of the Attorney General filed a civil
complaint alleging seven causes of
action against Trump and his
co-defendants for violating New York's
executive law the status seeking
dramatic remedies including the
discouragement of 250 million dollars in
Trump organization profits the
cancellation of business certificates
for Trump's corporate entities and a
five-year ban on Trump and his company
from entering into any New York
commercial real estate transactions
Tish James also wants to ban Trump and
his associates from applying for loans
from any New York entity and to stop
them from serving as an officer or
director of a New York Corporation this
would effectively destroy the Trump
organization all seven causes of action
are brought under New York executive
laws section 63 sub 12. this law
authorizes the New York attorney general
to bring civil lawsuits to enjoin
repeated fraudulent or illegal Acts or
persistent fraud or illegality in the
carrying on conducting or transaction of
business
the law is a broad Discovery tool for
prosecutors who only need to show a
capacity or tendency to deceive in order
to issue subpoenas before a complaint is
even filed
civil penalties include actual damages
discouragement of profits canceling of
corporate certificates and other
prohibitions that would effectively kill
the Trump organization's ability to do
business in New York
Trump is no stranger to New York's
executive law the New York attorney
general's office used it to sue Trump
University for fraud in 2013. in that
case the trial court ruled that section
63 sub 12 did not give the Attorney
General the ability to pursue fraud
claims only under the executive Law
Without proving that Trump University
violated State fraud statutes
however the Appellate Division reversed
that trial court ruling holding that the
Attorney General could use section 63
sub 12 as a catch-all anti-fraud statute
after the decision Trump settled the
case so thanks to the Trump University
case the Attorney General now has an
easier route for proving the Trump
organization committed fraud to prove a
violation of section 63 sub-12 the state
only has to show a pattern of fraudulent
or illegal business actions the term
fraudulent or deceptive practices
generally includes acts which may be
characterized as dishonest and
misleading the terms are not limited to
instances of intentional fraud in the
traditional sense now just to be clear
James is not criminally Prosecuting
Trump and the Trump Organization for tax
fraud James said she has evidence that
Trump and his family and corporate
officers committed crimes and she
referred those potential cases to the
IRS and to the Manhattan district
attorney Alvin brag but at this point
all we're talking about is a civil case
the Attorney General says investigators
uncovered over 200 false and misleading
valuations of assets for the 11
statements covered in 2011 through 2021
most large corporations use outside
accountants to compile their financial
statements the Attorney General says
that Trump rarely hired outside
professionals to prepare any of the
asset valuations for the statements on
the rare occasion that the organization
did get outside advice on how to Value
the assets the trumps routinely ignored
or contradicted their advice for example
an outside appraiser said the homes
Trump could build on as Aberdeen
Scotland Golf Course would result in a
Net Present Value profit of 16 to 19
million euros the equivalent of about 18
to 21.5 million dollars
the Trump organization allegedly ignored
that valuation and instead valued the
land at more than 300 million in Trump's
financial statements
the complaint alleges that Trump and his
partners and children committed
persistent acts of Fraud and that all of
this occurred in an atmosphere conducive
to fraud in which the goal of increasing
Mr Trump's reported net worth on the
statements was well known and carried
out by his agents and subordinates
all that conduct was directed toward
presenting misleading statements to
others including lenders insurance
companies and governmental entities the
acts of fraud alleged here were repeated
entailing among other things dozens of
specific numerical entries and financial
spreadsheets dozens of verbal
representations and financial statements
and other fraudulent and misleading
conduct by the defendants the state
argues that this conduct was persistent
and carried out by the same key players
over several years defendant Jeffrey
mcconney prepared or supervised
preparation of supporting spreadsheets
while Alan weisselberg reviewed and
approved spreadsheets and as trustee
certified the statement's accuracy
Donald Trump reviewed and approved
statements and certified their accuracy
Don Jr certified the statement's
accuracy as a trustee Ivanka was
involved in numerous real estate deals
in America and overseas the defendants
allegedly used this false information
year after year relying on prior year's
information to prepare new valuations
continuing the use of deceptive wording
and describing valuations performed and
continuing deceptive strategies used in
the prior Year's statements so what
about the defendant's mental state
unlike many of the state's anti-fraud
laws the executive law does not require
an intent to defraud the test to
determine whether a representation is
false is in its capacity to deceive so
what acts go to their capacity to
deceive the Attorney General says that
each defendant played a role in
certifying false statements about the
Trump organization and its properties
and that they conspired with each other
to mislead lenders and insurers the
Trump organization gave allegedly false
statements to Banks to induce those
institutions to rely on fake numbers
defendants also went to Great Lengths to
conceal their fraud when they submitted
financial information to mazars the
trumps allegedly excluded key
information such as lender-ordered
appraisals on a given property or
limitations on development like the
easements on mar-a-laga by doing this
defendants hid the correct valuation of
individual Properties by grouping them
together into categories like Club
facilities and related real estate the
complaint alleges that the defendants
also actively engaged in deception such
as failing to disclose the 30 brand
premium or avoiding the creation of
written records When Donald and Eric
were developing the Seven Springs Club
Mr Trump and his agents sought to avoid
creating a documentary record Mr Trump
advised his employee handling his real
estate Affairs in the lower Hudson
Valley which included Seven Springs that
he did not want Communications between
them put in writing and this ladies and
gentlemen is what we call a clue the
second cause of action alleges that the
defendants committed repeated fraud or
illegality by falsifying business
records in violation of state law under
New York penal law section
175.05 falsifying business records is
committed when with intent to defraud a
person a makes or causes a false entry
in the business records of an Enterprise
B Alters erases obliterates deletes
removes or destroys a true entry in the
business records of an Enterprise C
admits to make a true entry in the
business records of an Enterprise in
violation of a duty to do so which he
knows to be imposed upon Him by law or
by the nature of his position or finally
D prevents the making of a true entry or
causes the Omission thereof in the
business records of an Enterprise
the suit alleges that the Trump
organization kept two sets of books one
that overvalued properties when the
business sought loans from Banks and
another one that undervalued properties
for tax purposes this is a classic fraud
for example Trump Park Avenue is one of
the crown jewels in the Trump real
estate Empire its value allegedly Rose
from 90.9 million dollars in 2011 to 350
million dollars in 2021. unsold
residential condominium units owned by
Trump or the company represented the
Lion's Share of the reported value for
this property in excess of 95 percent in
some years so what's the catch well
these were actually rent controlled
units and outside Bank ordered appraisal
in 2010 valued the 12 rent stabilized
units at just 750 thousand dollars total
Trump allegedly withheld this appraisal
from mazars and never told mazars the
units were subject to rent control in
the 2020 appraisal the value of those
units Rose to 85 million dollars but the
Trump financial statements said that
they were valued at 135 million a lead
accountant who was involved in the
matter testified that he was shocked by
the size of the discrepancy and would
never have issued the financial
statements if he had been aware of the
2010 and 2020 appraisals and the rent
control restriction this is a classic
two sets of books situation the lawsuit
says that all of the defendants issued
false financial statements in violation
of penal law section 175.45
a person issues a false financial
statement under Section 175 45 when the
person with intent to fraud won
knowingly makes or utters a written
instrument which purports to describe
the financial condition of some person
and which is inaccurate in some material
respect or two represents in writing
that a written instrument purporting to
describe a person's Financial condition
as of a particular date is accurate with
respect to such persons Current
financial condition knowing it is
materially inaccurate in that respect
the state alleges that all defendants
acted with intent and a fraud knowingly
made or uttered materially inaccurate
written instruments purporting to
describe Donald Trump's Financial
condition
for example Trump's 212-acre Seven
Springs property consists of two large
homes undeveloped land and a few other
buildings an appraisal prepared by the
Royal Bank of Pennsylvania in 2000
estimated the as is value of Seven
Springs at 25 million dollars for
residential development and bank records
show that value Rose to 30 million
dollars in 2006. even the heating vents
are recessed under three inches of
marble with small little slits cut out
of them however between 2011 and 2021
valuations of Seven Springs ranged from
261 million dollars to 291 million
dollars
why
because the financial statements were
based on projections by Eric Trump who
said that he had gotten approval to
build seven luxurious mansions on the
property the lawsuit alleges that Eric
inflated the value of Seven Springs by
exaggerating development potential and
failing to account for the years of work
that were needed to make it happen
the implication of such evaluation is
that the Lots or homes were ready to
sell and would do so instantaneously a
false and misleading and indeed
impossible assumption Eric also
allegedly worked to get a federal tax
deduction by arranging a so-called
conservation easement donation that was
based on an inflated value for the land
his attempt to get a conservation
easement was a recognition that the
Trump organization would never be able
to develop the property for anything
approaching a 161 million dollar return
moving on to insurance fraud the
complaint alleges that the defendants
all committed insurance fraud New York
penal law article
176.05 defines insurance fraud as a
fraudulent Insurance act committed by
any person who knowingly and with intent
to defraud presents to an insurer one
any written statement in support of an
application for the issuance of
commercial or personal insurance that he
or she knows to a contain materially
false information concerning any fact
material or conceal for the purpose of
misleading information concerning any
fact material or two any written
statement or other physical evidence as
part of the issuance of a health
insurance policy or a claim for payment
services or other benefit pursuant to
such policy contract or plan that he or
she knows to a contain materially false
information concerning any material fact
or B conceal for the purpose of
misleading information concerning any
fact material the complaint says that
all defendants prepared and presented
written statements in support of
applications for insurance knowing they
contained materially false information
concerning facts material to those
applications it alleges the defendants
also concealed facts from insurers for
the purpose of misleading those insurers
the lawsuit provides details on two
Insurance scenarios where Aon Risk
Solutions was the broker and the trumps
are alleged to have submitted false
information a surety bond program with
Zurich North America and directors and
officers liability coverages from
Everest National and Tokyo Marine HCC
the Trump financial documents were key
components in its Insurance submissions
they were used to support Trump's
personal guarantee in lieu of collateral
and to misrepresent the valuations of
trump properties according to the
lawsuit the Trump organization only
allowed Underwriters to review Trump's
financial statements in person at Trump
organization offices the lawsuit alleges
that in addition to submitting false
financial statements Trump and his
organization failed to disclose an
investigation into Trump and other
employees that could have affected their
ability to obtain directors and officers
coverage Attorney General James claims
that the Trump organization also failed
to disclose that the golf courses listed
in Trump's statements included a
substantial brand premium baked into the
report evaluation under zurich's
underwriting guidelines intangible
assets like brand value have to be
excluded
had the Trump organization disclose the
brand premium Zurich would have reduced
that valuation finally the complaint
alleges that the defendants conspired to
break the law New York penal law Section
105 generally prohibits a person from
entering into a conspiracy to break the
law the attorney general alleges that
defendants are also liable for
persistent and repeated fraud under
executive law 63 sub 12 as participants
in a long-running conspiracy here the
actions of the defendants including
making numerous false and misleading
entries and emissions and financial
statements and supporting materials in a
similar manner over the course of more
than a decade and then submitting them
to financial institutions as certified
by Mr Trump or his trustees reflect the
existence of an agreement to commit
fraud within the meaning of section 63
sub 12. the state says that it can prove
that the defendants committed overtax
and further into the conspiracy as late
as 2019 2020 2021
and 2022 so the New York attorney
general has said that she can prove it
to get there and to talk about what that
proof actually entails we actually have
to talk about the Fifth Amendment
ratified as part of the Bill of Rights
in 1791 the Fifth Amendment is a shield
against prosecutorial overreach and a
Cornerstone of American Liberty the
Fifth Amendment provides five distinct
constitutional rights one the right to
indictment by a grand jury for felony
charges two prohibition on Double
Jeopardy meaning you can't be tried for
the same crime twice
three the right to a fair trial four no
government seizure of private property
without due compensation and five the
right against forced self-incrimination
and today we're just focused on that
last one the right against
self-incrimination
the Fifth Amendment provides in relevant
part no person shall be compelled in any
criminal case to be a witness against
himself you've probably heard this right
articulated and say Miranda warnings in
which the police are required to tell
suspects in police custody you have the
right to remain silent anything you say
can and will be used against you in a
court of law you have the right to
remain silent if you give up the right
to remain silent anything you say can
and will be held against you on a port
of law so when people take the fifth or
plead the fifth it means they've invoked
this right against being forced to give
testimony that could expose them to
criminal liability
the fifth amendment's protections cover
not just defendants but Witnesses in
both civil and criminal settings at the
state and federal level
however pleading the fifth is frequently
misunderstood by laypeople and
demagogues by politicians perhaps most
famously by Donald Trump himself the mob
takes if it if you're innocent why are
you taking the Fifth Amendment and of
course as is often the case with all
things Donald Trump there's always a
tweet of him saying something in the
past that is the exact opposite of what
he's saying today so why are we talking
about the Fifth Amendment because of
Trump's deposition even getting Trump to
sit for a deposition was a Herculean
task in January 2022 the Trump family
filed a motion to quash the subpoenas
arguing that ordering the trumps to
testify violated their constitutional
rights because their answers could be
used in the parallel criminal
investigation from the Manhattan
District Attorney's Office in February a
judge rejected those arguments and
ordered that the trumps sit for the
deposition that order was affirmed on
appeal in May notably Trump's senior was
also held in contempt of court and fined
ten thousand dollars a day for failing
to respond to a related subpoena for
documents the Elder Trump resolved this
contempt finding in May after paying one
hundred and ten thousand dollars in
fines Trump has long attacked the
legitimacy of the New York investigation
and has even tried to shut it down in
December 2021 Trump and his company
filed a federal lawsuit requesting the
Court's enter an injunction blocking
James's office from continuing to
investigate them Trump has also publicly
accused Attorney General James who is
Black of being racist and only
investigating Trump out of spite and
political ambition
when James first ran for attorney
general in 2018 she vowed to investigate
Trump if elected comments that Trump has
pointed to as evidence that this is just
another Witch Hunt in May 2022 a federal
judge dismissed Trump's lawsuit
rejecting his claims that he's being
targeted out of political animus and
allowing the investigation to continue
after delaying the deposition for a
month following the death of Trump's
first wife Trump finally sat for the
deposition on August 10 2022 Trump
arrived at James's office in lower
Manhattan in order to comply with the
court order to testify but when the
deposition began the typically
loquacious former president had very
little to say in response to questioning
a source with knowledge of the
deposition said that Trump took the
fifth more than 440 times declining to
answer every single question except one
what is your name the reason for this
High number of invocations is that
Witnesses who seek to invoke their Fifth
Amendment rights must assert the
privilege in response to particular
questions asked or evidence sought a
preemptive blanket assertion of the
fifth amendment in response to all
anticipated questions is not permitted
and any delay or failure to assert one's
Fifth Amendment rights may result in a
waiver of that privilege James asked
Trump a few preliminary questions but
the vast majority of the deposition was
conducted by her Deputy according to
Trump attorney Ron fischetti Trump
repeated the same answer of invoking his
Fifth Amendment right not to testify
over and over again for the nearly
four-hour deposition they asked a lot of
questions about valuations and golf
clubs and all that stuff fachetti told
the New York Times foschetti claimed
Trump actually wanted to answer the
questions but had to be be talked out of
it by his attorneys he absolutely wanted
to testify and it took some very strong
persuasion by me and some others to
convince him fishetti said now after
this deposition Trump posted the
following on Truth social a very
professional meeting have a fantastic
company with great assets very little
debt and lots of cash only in America
Trump also put out a more fiery formal
statement that called the investigation
the greatest Witch Hunt in the history
of our country and accused James of
openly campaigning on a policy of
destroying me Trump also detailed why he
had a change of heart about taking the
fifth but in typical trumpian fashion he
said that even though he's totally
innocent he had no choice but to plead
the fifth because everyone is corrupt
and out to get him for no reason
I once asked if you're innocent why are
you taking the Fifth Amendment now I
know the answer to that question when
your family your company and all the
people in your orbit have become the
targets of unfounded politically
motivated Witch Hunt supported by
lawyers prosecutors in the fake news
media you have no choice accordingly
under the advice of my counsel and for
all the above reasons I declined to
answer the questions under the rights
and privileges afforded to every citizen
under the United States Constitution
despite Trump's claim that he had no
choice he did in fact have a choice
after all his daughter Ivanka and Son
Don Jr were deposed by the New York
attorney general's office and they
answered questions instead of pleading
the fifth also it might surprise you to
learn that Trump was not being entirely
truthful about his experience with the
Fifth Amendment I I know it's hard to
believe
in fact Donald Trump is quite familiar
with pleading the fifth in far less
serious matters during his contentious
divorce with his recently deceased first
wife Ivana Trump Mr Trump was asked 100
questions from ivana's lawyers over the
course of five depositions that related
to marital infidelity Trump pleaded the
fifth in response to 97 of them given
that the marriage famously fell apart
due to Donald's tabloid affair with
model actress and future wife Marla
Maples Mr Trump likely calculated he
would be better off simply not answering
questions about said Affair than
admitting to it on the record and that
strategy seems to have worked well for
him later bragging that he managed to
settle the divorce without giving Ivana
a penny more than required by the
prenuptial agreement and even following
ivana's death Trump seemed to relish not
spending a lot of money on the mother of
his adult children now you might be
thinking hold on a second I thought we
were talking about a civil case and not
a criminal case and you're absolutely
right so let's go back to the complaint
near York civil fraud complaint makes
repeated references to Donald Trump son
Eric Trump and former Trump CFO Alan
weisselberg repeatedly invoking the
fifth amendment in Leticia James's press
conference announcing the civil suit the
New York attorney general also cited
weisselberg and Trump seniors invoking
the Fifth Amendment when asked about
their potentially fraudulent activities
the implication of James's references is
that the defendants had the opportunity
to defend themselves from allegations of
fraud but repeatedly chose not to
suggesting consciousness of guilt
but like most things involving Donald
Trump the New York investigation has
inspired commentators to adopt some very
bad legal takes like for example senior
Fox Business editor Jay Caruso who
tweeted invoking constitutional rights
as evidence of committing a crime great
precedent now Caruso snark aside he's
actually just making an incorrect
statement of the law and I know I know a
Fox News personality saying something
demonstrably inaccurate this is the
first time for everything
when someone pleads the fifth in a
criminal setting prosecutors may not
comment on the defendant's refusal to
testify as evidence of guilt nor May a
jury be instructed to interpret a
defendant's silence as a sign of guilt
in Griffin V California the U.S Supreme
Court ruled that prosecutors may not use
the defendant's refusal to testify as
substantive evidence of guilt as doing
so would illegally penalize defendants
for availing themselves to the fifth
amendment's constitutional protections
even though prosecutors can't use
defendant silence against them in
criminal cases that same silence or
refusal to answer can have severe
consequences in a civil context that's
because in both a private civil case and
a state civil enforcement action a judge
or jury can draw adverse inferences to
support liability when the defendant
invokes the Fifth Amendment something
that is absolutely not permitted in
criminal cases this principle was
articulated by the Supreme Court in
backs
the Fifth Amendment does not forbid
adverse inferences against parties to
civil actions when they refuse to
testify in response to probative
evidence offered against them the
amendment does not preclude the
inference where the Privileges claimed
by a party to a civil cause and in
August 10 2022 interview with MSNBC
lawyer and former FBI special agent Asha
rangappa explained just how devastating
taken to fifth could be for Trump
against a civil enforcement action in a
criminal case a jury cannot draw
inferences of guilt from someone
asserting their Fifth Amendment right
but in a civil case a jury can draw an
adverse inference and there's a lower
standard of proof it's a preponderance
of the evidence and in that in a civil
case though what Trump is facing are
potential Financial penalties other
legal commentators have noted that while
pleading the fifth helps protect the
trumps from Criminal liability that same
refusal to answer questions leaves them
quite vulnerable to James's civil action
former Federal prosecutor Renato
Mariotti wrote as much on Twitter the
New York AG has a lot of Leverage in
this lawsuit because Trump and his son
Eric took the fifth hundreds of times
that was smart to do but it means
they're screwed in the civil case a jury
would likely be instructed to presume
their answers would have hurt Trump
in short the reason Caruso's statement
is legally incorrect is that it fails to
note the distinction between invoking
your fifth amendment rights in a
criminal context versus a civil setting
and in that respect James isn't creating
new precedent so much as she's relying
on case law that's existed for nearly 50
years and when Caruso's misstatement of
law was pointed out by National Security
lawyer Bradley P moss on Twitter Caruso
responded with the grace and Contrition
we've come to expect from Fox News by
which I mean none at all so that's it
that is the legal basis for the New York
state civil enforcement action against
Donald Trump the Trump organization his
kids and a bunch of other randos so on
behalf of the legal eagle special Trump
unit and Devin sanity I just want to say
please for the love of God can we just
end this insane news cycle
this is
oh God that's terrible
oh no
no no no
special Trump unit
of this 24 hour news cycle just can't
die
oh no no not again not again not another
one
[Laughter]
no no we can't because if Leticia James
is right as we discussed she'll use the
invocation to the Fifth Amendment to
destroy the Trump organization and there
were about to be a whole bunch of trump
org employees and middle-aged Trump
adult children that are out of a job and
of course they could all really benefit
from today's sponsor 80 000 hours 80 000
hours is a non-profit helps people find
careers that aim to solve the world's
most pressing problems have you ever
taken a career aptitude test where they
just ask you to list a bunch of
preferences and then it tells you to be
like a structural engineer and you feel
confused about what it's based on and
what you've been recommending I know I
took tons of those and none of them
recommended YouTube lawyer that's
because most career advice is Cookie
Cutter and it focuses on a few
mainstream and obvious paths and doesn't
take into account the best available
evidence about how to actually find a
fulfilling career and most importantly
relevant career advice can be really
hard to find if you care a lot about
making a big positive difference in the
world and many sources on this topic
only recommend a few well-known career
paths that people often think have a
high social impact like I don't know
being a doctor a teacher charity worker
boo no those are great but those aren't
your only options and they probably
aren't even your best options 80 000
hours is a nonprofit that aims to help
you find a career that is both
fulfilling and makes a big positive
difference the name comes from the
number of hours an average career takes
40 hours a week 50 weeks a year for 40
years that's a lot of time and that
means that your career is probably the
biggest opportunity to have an impact 80
000 hours has done over 10 years of
research alongside academics at Oxford
University into how to find a fulfilling
career that does a lot of good and it
turns out that the best way to make a
positive difference might be pretty
different from what you'd think and they
always try to avoid platitudes and
unsupported generalizations in fact all
of their recommendations are based on
careful research and consultation with
experts in relevant fields and when they
aren't sure of something they say so so
if you care about what the evidence
actually says about having a fulfilling
and impactful career than 80 000 hours
can help plus everything they provide is
free forever because they're a
non-profit their only aim is to help
solve Global Problems by helping people
find the most impactful careers they can
so this one is a no-brainer if you're
thinking about your career if you'd like
a free copy of 80 000 hours in-depth
career guide that helps you learn about
what makes for a high impact career get
new ideas for impactful paths and makes
a new plan based on what you've learned
then just click on the link in the
description or on the screen right now
you'll get access to their free
newsletter with updates on their
research and high impact job
opportunities again all you have to do
is click on the link that's in the
description or on screen right now to
start planning for a career that is
Meaningful fulfilling and helps solve
some of the world's most pressing
problems and after that click on this
link over here for more legaleagle or
I'll see you in court